Speaker 1: All right, Now, I promise I'm
not going to do this every single day,
but it's just too delightful not to briefly talk
about it. On Tucker Carlson's latest replacement,
second night filling in for the now fired Tucker
Carlson on Fox News. Lawrence Jones again,
just made a complete and total fool out of himself
yesterday. We talked about it and I said, hey,
you know what, guys? This guy may not be ready
for primetime. He just doesn't really seem to
have what it takes to put it very likely.
He was on again yesterday and it's confused
word salad after a confused word salad from
Lawrence Jones. It's I almost am feeling a
little bad for him. Like, isn't it so obvious?
He's nowhere even remotely close to ready to
do this. He had a Democrat, I guess he's usually
called Democratic strategist Julian Epstein on.
And I mean, he tries to make some point. And
it's just so confusing. It's it's really a
Trumpian word salad. Listen to this.
Speaker 2: The immigration policy,
the Democrats say that this is a race issue
with. I just can't help but look at history
when it came from black Americans that came
across the border unwillingly. It's three
constitutional amendments and an entire war to
get black Americans the right of average American
citizens. So I did The Democrats have a
different application of the law here.
Speaker 1: I just have no clue what he's talking
about. It's something about brown people from
Mexico being treated differently. He seems to
be saying we needed civil war to end slavery of
black people. But Democrats want to treat Brown
people from Mexico different. I just don't even
know what he's talking about. And this is the
reaction from people who are still watching this,
which is not that many people. I have to tell
you. He's just not very good at this. There
was another segment where he had Lee Fang Lee
Fang on, who's been a guest on the program,
and I guess he's trying to Lawrence Jones is
trying to explain the First Republic Bank failure,
which we talked about yesterday on the award
winning globally famous bonus show. And I
don't know, he says something about diversity
and I don't even know what he's talking about.
Speaker 2: Yeah. So they recruited all these
minorities and their bank still filled. So
all the minorities that bank that that they're
they're screwed. The governing government is
saying they're going to help them, but it just
doesn't seem like they solved the problem. Lee,
thanks so much for joining the program.
Speaker 1: Okay. I don't know what he
means by they're screwed. I mean,
JPMorgan Chase bought the bank.
There's FDIC insurance. It's not the government's
going to do something special to bail up bail them
out. They're just there is FDIC insurance. And so
their deposits are are insured. Visibly confused
throughout the entire hour. I don't think
Lawrence Jones is going to be the eventual
replacement to Tucker Carlson. But listen, I
could be wrong. We will have to wait and see.